Hallo ihr Lieben, heute gibt's herzhafte Feta Pasta!
Und zwar machen wir die in der Pfanne, aber auch im Ofen. Das Ganze ist einfach richtig cool!
Das ist gerade so ein kleiner TikTok Hype aber ich habe dieses Rezept auch schon auf amerikanischen Plattformen gesehen
- Ich glaube das schwappt gerade so ein bisschen rüber - und ich finde, das sollten wir jetzt auch mal ausprobieren!
[Kiki] Und zwar brauchen wir -
[Hamza] Wir schwimmen den Strom mit, Kiki!
[Kiki] Ja wir schwimmen auch mal mit dem Strom, genau!
Also, ihr braucht zuallererst entweder eine Auflaufform oder eine Pfanne, die ihr in den Backofen geben könnt.
Ich nehme da natürlich meine Hochrand-Pfanne.
Und da geben wir jetzt zuallererst..
- Nicht wundern, die ganz genauen Mengenangaben stehen unten in der Videobeschreibung! -
Da geben wir jetzt zuallererst Olivenöl rein. Das muss richtig gutes Olivenöl sein, das schmackhaft ist,
kaltgepresst und am besten nativ extra.
Und das gebe ich jetzt hier einfach erstmal auf den Boden.
Dann gebe ich da direkt meinen Fetakäse in die Mitte
und gebe auf den Fetakäse auch nochmal Olivenmehl.
[Kiki] Äh - äh, Olivenöl!
[Hamza] Olivenöl, ja!
[Hamza] Interessant. Ich kann mich jetzt gar nicht mit dem Rezept identifizieren, überhaupt nicht!
[Kiki] Du weißt noch nicht, was passiert, ne?
[Hamza] Keine Ahnung!
[Kiki] Hamza hat das nämlich gar nicht mitbekommen!
[Hamza] Nee!
[Kiki] Ich war die letzten Tage viel auf TikTok unterwegs.
[Hamza] Aber ich muss sagen: Eigentlich ist TikTok genau meine Plattform!
[Kiki] TikTok ist voll was für uns!
[Hamza] Einfach cringe, genauso wie ich!
[Kiki] Ich werde euch - aber wir sind ja auch relativ aktiv!
Ich verlinke euch mal unseren TikTok Account hier unten in der Videobeschreibung.
[Kiki] Wir sind recht aktiv Hamza, definitiv!
[Hamza] Auf jeden Fall!
So, ich geb da jetzt Tomaten dazu. Auch richtig schöne, aromatische Tomaten benutzen!
Und da kommt gleich der Saft aus den Tomaten raus weil das kommt ja gleich in den Backofen.
Was ich jetzt auch noch habe, sind Zwiebeln und Knoblauch.
Hab ich hier schon in feine Scheiben geschnitten und den Knoblauch gehackt.
So... diesmal hab ich den Knoblauch nicht gepresst weil so kann ich ihn besser verteilen.
[Hamza] Okay... und das kommt in den Ofen jetzt rein, oder was?
Genau. Warte ab, das wird noch richtig cool! Jetzt salze ich das ein bisschen...
An Gewürzen könnt ihr euch jetzt austoben. Ich nehme italienische Kräuter
und ein bisschen scharfe Paprika, aber nur ein bisschen!
So! Ich glaube, das war mir ein bisschen zu wenig Olivenöl
also gerne noch mal ein bisschen Olivenöl oben drauf geben.
Und jetzt müsst ihr das Ganze in den Backofen schieben.
Und zwar bei 190°C Ober- und Unterhitze für ungefähr 18-20min.
Ihr werdet dann merken, dass euer Fetakäse schön weich wird,
dass die Tomaten richtig schön das Wasser lassen...
Ah, das Wasser lassen! Das sagt man auch zu was anderem, ne?
[Kiki] Ihr wisst, wie ich das meine!
[Hamza] Ja, die machen Pipi, Kiki! *lacht*
Auf jeden Fall gebe ich das jetzt in den Backofen!
Und in der Zwischenzeit werde ich schon mal entweder Spaghetti oder irgendwelche anderen Nudeln gar kochen.
[Kiki] Da können wir gleich mal gucken, welche wir da nehmen, ne?
[Hamza] M-hm!
So!
Also.. Spaghetti, Penne, Farfalle? Farfalle?
[Hamza] Was ist Farfalle? Ich nehm Falafel!
Schmetterlingsnudeln!
[Hamza] Kiki, mir ist das egal! Schmeckt doch alles gleich!
[Kiki] Oder so Muscheln?
[Hamza] Nee!
[Kiki] Nee?
[Kiki] Oder hier so..?
[Hamza] NEIN!
[Kiki] Okay, sach an!
[Hamza] Kinder sind so kompliziert!
[Hamza] Keine Ahnung, nimm was du willst! Nimm Spaghetti, ich find Spaghetti cool!
[Kiki] Meinst du Spaghetti sieht hübscher aus?
[Hamza] Warte!
[Hamza] Du siehst hübsch aus!
[Kiki] Ohhh!
[Hamza] *lacht* Ah, wirst du jetzt rot? Na?
[Hamza] Du weißt nicht, was du sagen sollst!
[Kiki] Hör auf damit!
[Kiki] Also Hamza was jetzt? Ich find die sehen auch ganz cool aus!
[Kiki] ..aber ich glaub in der Soße..
[Hamza] Nimm Spaghetti, das sieht für Fotos immer schöner aus!
[Kiki] Ja! So, dann koche ich jetzt ganz einfach in Salzwasser gar.
So, der Fetakäse ist jetzt gerade aus dem Ofen gekommen
und jetzt geben wir die gar gekochte Spaghetti einfach mit dazu.
Und das Schöne ist, dass jetzt der Fetakäse richtig schön weich ist
und zusammen mit den ganzen anderen Zutaten jetzt schon die Soße ergibt.
Und das war's auch schon mit dem Essen, also.. fertig ist es schon!
[Hamza] Das war's schon?
[Kiki] Das war's schon, ja!
Also das Besondere kommt jetzt.
Oah, das war nicht so klug!
Wer mag, kann jetzt noch nachsalzen. Ich fand's jetzt so eigentlich perfekt!
Ich würd mal sagen ich verabschiede mich für meinen Teil bei euch.
Würd mich natürlich freuen, wenn ihr dem Video ein Däumchen nach oben da lasst und natürlich ein kostenloses Abo.
Und falls ihr irgendwelche Rezepttrends kennt oder sagt "Hey, das hab ich irgendwo gesehen",
dann schreibt mir das doch in die Kommentare und ich mache es dann für euch!
Wer jetzt noch dranbleibt, sieht im Anschluss den legendären Taste Test von Hamza
und ich wünsche euch ganz viel Spaß damit!
Tschüss, eure Kiki!
[Hamza] So! Probieren wir mal, ne?
[Hamza] Ich glaub Spaghetti in der Kamera zu essen ist echt nicht einfach, ne?
[Hamza] Oder vor der Kamera besser gesagt!
[Kiki] Kannst auch 'nen Löffel nehmen!
[Hamza] Nee es geht schon, geht schon klar. Dauert nur 'nen Moment aber es geht!
[Hamza] Jetzt hab ich alle Komponenten drauf, oder? Warte mal, ich brauch noch bisschen Mozzarella.
[Kiki] Feta!
[Hamza] Äh Fetakäse, sorry. Feta!
[Hamza] M-hm! Sehr würzig durch den Feta und die Tomate macht's so ein bisschen nasser, so ein bisschen feuchter, ne?
[Hamza] Also ich weiß nicht, was ich dazu sagen soll! Das sind ganz normale Spaghetti mit Fetakäse!
[Hamza] Also es schmeckt gut, auf jeden Fall! Ist auch geil gewürzt aber ist jetzt kein Rezept, bei dem ich sage: "Woow, geil!"
[Hamza] Schmeck gut auf jeden Fall weil's auch schnell geht. Super einfach und schnell.
[Hamza] In Ordnung, ist cool!
[Kiki] Ja, cool, ja!
[Kiki] Ehrliche Kritik! Also man muss ehrlich sein: Das ist ein schnelles Rezept, ne?
[Hamza] Das ist ein schnelles Rezept, also was soll ich dazu sagen?
[Hamza] Das ist jetzt nicht so wie Penne Honey, wo es so richtig geil ist mit dem Honig, wo es harmoniert..
[Hamza] Das ist ein ganz anderer Geschmack, weißte? Da hast du eine Geschmacksexplosion drin!
[Hamza] Ja wie gesagt, das ist halt kein ausgefallenes Nudelrezept!
Also ich glaube dadurch, dass du den Fetakäse in den Backofen gemacht hast, hat er sich glaub ich bisschen mehr entfaltet als sonst üblich so.
[Kiki] Ja, es ist auf jeden Fall was anderes als wenn man's drüber bröseln lässt!
[Hamza] Genau!
[Kiki] Aber kann man mal machen zwischendurch, ne?
[Hamza] Auf jeden Fall, weil's auch schnell geht, ist ja auch einfach!
[Hamza] Auf jeden Fall, kann man mal probieren!
[Kiki] Okay Hamza, Dankeschön!
[Hamza] Bitteschön! Ich hab jetzt Hunger und deswegen schieb ich euch jetzt zur Seite und sag Tschüss!
[Hamza] Peace and out!
[Hamza] Pew!
[Hamza] Du warst zu langsam Kiki, du warst zu langsam!
[Hamza] Du musst es nochmal neu machen!
[Kiki] Okay, nochmal!
[Hamza] Pew!
[Kiki] War das jetzt schnell genug?
[Hamza] Ja!
[Hamza] Achso! Jaja! *lacht*